welcome to this video playing chess Rex
so I need to find a good balance between
offbeat and and still playable I had one
or two really really bad openings them
and I don't want that again so let's see
what is this really this is good Wow ok
I take that
what about d5 you could might go e5
yeah I'm aware that this is a bit
dangerous but still okay it's not even
going for Bishop d3 why am I even
worrying ok ok yeah this King this King
is shaky I know why I don't play five
normally and f5 how do I get this
developed now Bishop man maybe I have to
do this or e6 that has at least queen
edge for sometimes
even as 95 immediately because of Queen
age five kim looks a bit sick but
probably castles is really right I was
thinking I could meet you for long
castling but I don't have the time for
that
yeah that's definitely dangerous he's
gotten lots of attacking potential
Bishop age six is coming king age eight
Queen age three is immediately lost Wow
yeah one misstep in those cheeky
openings with the air porn and your
toasted right terrible I mean it's not
lost i think but it's just so
uncomfortable they're getting it here he
played every year which is probably
complete rubbish if you know how to
handle it but the way it went out here
in this game I just just under heavy
fire
okay that looks maybe that's okay the
Nigeria five that looks like it it helps
to defend a bit what why is this not
losing material it is losing material I
was lucky that was a huge attack really
a huge attack
check check ya got Queens traded always
helpful white resins Jerry I don't know
I don't know what what is good after and
three years I don't believe that one bit
yeah f 3 i'd look strange but he really
got a huge huge game them maybe d5 is
better something like that no II for
your really more flexible that's some
kind of Staunton gambit but the sisters
felled a very dangerous but I cannot
avoid taking it now I have to take this
is just just not right yeah this is just
not looking good so this yeah I was far
more worried about Bishop d3 of course
like you mean sometimes sometimes you
can even do things like that i mean not
sure if this is on here but it's very
dangerous everything but that is also
dangerous so i put this on the board the
engine gives that with the huge
advantage yeah queen age five probably
yeah something like that is is already
annihilated check now you're toast can
get one check g6 and and over
amazing gads a super strong attack even
here yeah it's very strong here and
tonight g5 was winning that was winning
already yeah just go some can just take
him back via text with his eyes pieces
and this stuff is not playing and no one
Wow yeah it's here here I'm bet I am no
I'm better he gifted me a couple of
Tempe and this is a gifting piece yeah
he I think I mean okay that's an that's
an old story I always say that they
played too quickly but I don't really
don't really know this is a very
promising position and you he was like
two minutes up so we can easily take
like let's say 30 seconds and try to
really find it we move and not just play
the first move that comes to mind I mean
this is it doesn't look bad but well
you're two minutes up then let's say it
30 seconds for really good move when I
g5s it's not really difficult to see g6
you will take here it's easy like h6
looks also rubbish yeah 95 just wins the
whole thing but he played a bit too
quickly and let me back into the game
okay well thanks for watching